when August the 4th 1892 Andrew and Abby
Borden were brutally murdered in their
home in Fall River Massachusetts their
heads had been split open in a fit of
rage from nearly a dozen blows from a
hatchet
there was no theft there was no sign of
a break-in there 32 year old daughter
Lizzie Borden was at home when her
parents were killed she inherited her
father's multi-million dollar fortune
and everyone in Fall River believed that
she had killed her parents in cold blood
but in the end that simply was not
enough evidence to convict her and she
was allowed to go free nearly a hundred
and twenty years later the case is still
an unsolved mystery so did Lizzie Borden
really kill her parents or is the
identity of the real killer
still unknown Andrew Borden came from a
long line of wealthy and successful
people but his own parents struggled
with poverty as a young man he started
working as an underwriter at a bank in
Fall River Massachusetts he used his
paychecks to purchase investment real
estate and ran furniture and textile
businesses he was eventually promoted as
the manager of the bank even though he
was making a lot of money he only paid
for the bare necessities for himself and
for his family his fortune it grew to
over $300,000 which in modern-day
dollars is about eight million he
married a woman named Sarah
Anthony Morse and they had three
children together Emma was the oldest
they had a second daughter named Alice
who died as a baby Lizzie Borden was the
youngest daughter born in 1860 when she
was only two years old Lizzie's mother
Sarah became gravely ill and I was 12 at
the time so she was old enough to
remember the death of her sister Allison
fully understood the gravity of losing
their mother on her deathbed a mass war
to take care of baby Lizzie like a
mother and she took that promise
incredibly seriously
three years after Sarah's death Andrew
Borden married a woman named Abby Durfee
Emma who was 15 at the time refused to
address Abby as mother and called her by
her first name her entire childhood
Lizzie grew up to be very close with her
sister Emma who truly did feel more like
a mother
and a big sister however this backfired
because teenage Emma was constantly
reminding her younger sister that their
birth mother was dead because of this
lizzie never formed a close relationship
with her stepmother she later described
their relationship as cordial but she
grew up feeling as though she never
really knew a mother's love we don't
know much about the intimate details of
Lizzie's relationship with her father
except that he was a very busy man as he
had a full-time job and also ran his own
businesses on the side
Lizzie claimed to love him very much but
his shrewd business tactics and lack of
empathy for customers defaulting on some
of their loans caused some people in
town to dislike him as well as his
family Lizzie Borden's elementary school
teachers described her as being aloof so
she was either painfully shy or felt as
though she didn't want to make friends
she was also known for having dramatic
mood swings she could either be very
relaxed and unemotional while she could
burst out in a fit of rage this is not
uncommon for children who have lost
their parents at a young age but she was
severely neglected considering the
tragedy that had befallen their family
the wealthy members of the extended
Borden family lived in mansions up in a
fashionable neighborhood called the hill
they enjoyed an easy life with teams of
servants at their beck and call Andrew
Borden on the other hands rented half of
a duplex for his family and waited until
his children were grown to buy that
house and combine both arms into a
single home he never installed
electricity or indoor plumbing even
though it was actually quite affordable
at that time as she grew older Liz he
began to learn more about her extended
family who lived up on the hill her
cousins were always attending parties
and dances and went to the local theater
together with young people their own age
Lizzie wanted to join the rest of her
friends but Andrew Borden thought that
these activities were simply a waste of
money he never gave his daughters and
allowance to attend any of these social
outings living in a working-class
neighborhood Emma and Lizzie seemed far
too rich to fit in where they lived and
yet their father never gave the money to
socialize up on the hill they were stuck
in an isolating situation and they felt
like outcasts her cousins all married
rich men and their fathers paid dowries
than by their own houses meanwhile
Lizzie and Emma were still living with
their parents and their only social
interactions came from church related
events Lizzie Borden really only had one
close friends and that was her neighbor
Alice Russell many people who knew
Lizzie Borden before the murders said
that she was a gentle person with a kind
heart she would leave slices of
chocolate cake for men who came to her
father's house for maintenance and
insisted on tipping the groundskeeper
whenever her father was too cheap to do
it himself she also gave candita local
children along with cards that were
signed from auntie Borden even though
women were not allowed to hold a job at
the time Lizzie kept herself busy she
taught Sunday school to the local
children in Fall River and most people
in town knew of her as being a very
pious and a religious woman she was also
heavily involved in local women's
charity groups while she testified that
she loved her father very much less he
fundamentally disagreed in the way he
handled his money she also believed that
her stepmother was trying to take
advantage of his fortune when she was 27
years old Lizzie's father gave a house
to his wife's half-sister for free this
made Bizzy and Emma furious because they
were his own daughters and yet he had
never given them such an extravagant
gift when he realized how unfair this
was he gave his daughters the deed to
the house he grew up in to try and
pacify them however there was a strict
code of etiquette that unmarried women
could not live alone since Lizzie and
Emma never found husbands owning the
deed to their grandfather's home was
virtually useless and they were never
allowed to move out of their father's
house they eventually sold the house
back to their father for $5,000 even
after doing this it was still not enough
to make up for the jealousy the
resentment that Lizzie felt towards her
stepmother Abby Lizzie Borden was
unhappy living with her father and her
stepmother and she spent as much time as
possible out of the house soon after
their arguments about the houses Andrew
Borden agreed to let this he visit
Europe but the trip only made her
realize just how much she had missed in
her younger years when she returned
homes of the United States she often
chosen not to eat meals with her parents
and went up to the bedroom without even
saying hello live in the boarding house
it went on like this for several more
years in 1892 Lizzie Borden was 32 years
old and
sister Emma was 42 neither of them had
gotten married in the 1800s
this made them spinsters or women who
were considered to be far too old to
find a husband's there is no record of
why they never married but their family
issues clearly had something to do with
it
Lizzie continued to devote herself to
the church as well as local animal
rescue she was raising a family of
pigeons on their property and she loved
them like pets in June of that same year
Andrew purchased the hatchet and started
killing Lizzie's birds so that he could
save money on the meat
Lizzie may have felt that her window of
opportunity to escape this dysfunctional
family and find a better life was
closing in on her a father was 70 years
old and she needed to face the
possibility that he may die soon if his
money was controlled by her stepmother
Abby she knew things would get much
worse at any moments Lizzie Borden and
assist amma's lives were going to be
over unless they did something to stop
it
as we mentioned earlier Andrew and Abby
Borden were murdered on August the 4th
1892 the events leading up to their
murders may give a clue as to what may
have really happened on that fateful day
on August the 2nd the entire Borden
family was feeling sick Abby Borden
visited a local doctor asking if it was
possible that her bread had been
poisoned her doctor said that it was far
more likely that she simply ate some
rotten meat and that everyone in the
house was suffering from food poisoning
this was not uncommon back then since
there were no refrigerators to keep meat
and cheese from going bad in the summer
heat on August the 3rd the night before
the murders Lizzie and Emma's uncle John
Moores showed up unannounced he did not
bring any luggage but he asked to stay
the night John Moores he was the brother
of Sarah Moore Sandra's first wife and
the girl's biological uncle for whatever
reason this made Lizzie Borden feel
uneasy she told her friends Alice
Russell that she was terrified that
someone was about to hurt their family
according to his testimony
John boss woke up at 6:00 a.m. the next
day on August 4th Brigid the maid cooked
food for her masters and guests and
served their breakfast to Addie Andrew
and John around 7:00 a.m.
John announced that he was going to see
his other relatives in town and left the
house at around 8:30 in the morning
Lizzie said that she was feeling sick so
she never said hello to her uncle or
came down to eat breakfast with her
family Andrew Borden went to work at the
bank around 9:00 a.m. according to the
maid Bridget mrs. Borden asked her to
wash the windows outside that day and
she said that she would make the bet and
do the laundry in the guest bedroom when
Bridget was done washing the windows she
was feeling exhausted from working in
the summer heat and she was still sick
to her stomach she had been vomiting in
the backyard and desperately needed some
rest
Andrew was feeling sick at work so he
returned home around 11:00 a.m. but all
of the doors were locked with a deadbolt
so his key to the front door they would
have work this was strange and he
pounded on the door to have someone let
him in
Bridget rushed in the front door and
unlocked it Andrew Borden decided to
take a nap on the living-room couch
hoping that he could sleep off his
sickness during his lunch break
Bridget saw this as an opportunity to
rest so she went up to her bed
in the Attic to take a nap as well
Lizzie claims that she had to go outside
to the barn to look for a fishing lure
for a trip that she was taking the
following weekend according to a
testimony during that small 10 to 15
minute window of time outside someone
had taken a hatchet to her father's face
11 times his eyeballs were cut in half
his nose was gone and he was barely
recognizable as a person anymore
Lizzie walked back into the house and
when she saw a father's mutilated body
she screamed she called to Bridget to
tell her that her father was dead she
ran next door to a neighbor called
Adelaide Churchill saying and mrs.
Churchill do come over someone has
killed father they notified the police
and the family doctor who arrived to
examine the body by that time everyone
in the neighborhood knew about the crime
Andrew Borden's wounds were still fresh
suggesting that the attack it happens
very recently there's his friend Alice
Russell rushed over to the house to see
what was wrong Lizzie she was hysterical
and leaned on Alice for comfort Lizzie
asked Bridget to check upstairs first
stepmother saying well someone find mrs.
Borden mrs. Borden was lying face down
on the floor of one of the guest
bedrooms she had also been killed by an
axe but this time in the back of the
head mrs. Burton's blood was dry and
medical examiner's estimated that she
died in roughly two hours before her
husband's this would mean that the
killer must have been in the house the
entire time waiting for the perfect
opportunity to kill Andrew Borden
Lizzie's sister Emma was out of town
visiting her friends and they had to
send a telegram telling her to come home
she had a solid alibi about her
whereabouts so the police removed her as
a potential suspect Ridgid the maid was
home but she had nothing to gain by
killing her masters she was also removed
as a potential suspect by the police
when the police arrived it was noted
that no one in the house was covered in
blood
if Lizzie Borden really did kill her
father she would have blood spattered
all over our clothes she would not have
been able to clean herself off within a
matter of 10 minutes especially without
any running water in the house but
considering she was one of the only
people home at the time and that she had
the most to gain from her parents deaths
all eyes were on her
[Music]
Lizzie and Emma Borden stood with their
family members and her father's business
associates at their parents funeral
instead of watching their parents
caskets get buried in the grounds the
police ordered the bodies the taken for
a second autopsy the police also had
free rein to search the entire house
from top to bottom and yes they couldn't
find the murder weapon or any solid
evidence that would prove the identity
of the killer Lizzie Borden was
questioned by the police for several
hours and her answers were sometimes
inconsistent as if she couldn't quite
get her story straight the police saw
this as evidence that she was lying
however her doctor had injected her with
morphine before each interview saying
that it would help calm her nerves these
injections would have made her feel
mentally cloudy and confused in some
cases the drug can even cause delusions
and hallucinations despite having this
drug running through her veins tree
still never confessed to killing her
parents leading up to the trial Emma
Borden and Alice Russell witnessed
Lizzie Borden burning one of her dresses
in the backyard she claims that she was
simply disposing of old clothes that
have paint stains on them she gave the
police the blue dress that everyone had
witnessed her wearing the day of the
murders and it was completely free of
blood they also never found a bloody
dress when searching the house but the
police saw the burning of the mystery
dress as a sign that she may have
changed out of the clothes that she
killed her parents in and she was trying
to destroy the evidence Lizzie Borden
was arrested on suspicion of killing her
parents and she was taken to a holding
cell in a women's prison the dates of
the trial were from June 5th to 20th of
1893 this was nearly a year after the
death of her parents a pharmacist named
Eli Benz testified in court that Lizzie
Borden requested to buy potassium
cyanide the day before the murder but he
refused to sell it to her because he
suspected that she had terrible
intentions when the police exhumed the
bodies of mr. and mrs. Borden the
autopsy report showed that they had
never been poisoned it was just bad food
after all this meant mr. Benz his claim
didn't prove that Lizzie did anything
wrong her neighbor and friend Alice
Russell also testified against her about
burning the dress however without having
the actual dress on hands they still
could not prove that there was ever any
blood on it often nearly a year
to prepare their case the police had
nothing but circumstantial evidence
against her and it was simply not enough
to prove that she was guilty the members
of the jury they were all men which was
customary at the time all of them had a
very hard time believing that the same
woman who was the Sunday school teacher
could really be the same monster who
committed cold-blooded murder they
thought it more likely that a prowler
broke into the home and killed mr. and
mrs. Borden they only took 90 minutes to
make the decision that she was not
guilty after a parents deaths Lizzie and
her sister Emma split their father's
inheritance in half and it was more than
enough money to take care of them for
the rest of their lives they could
finally afford to buy a luxurious house
on the hill called maple croft they also
hired a staff of maids and a driver to
take them anywhere they wanted to go in
a horse-drawn coach Lizzie changed her
name to Lizbeth after moving in in hopes
of escaping her reputation in her minds
the life on the hill may have seemed
like a million miles away but the
reality was that they were still in Fall
River her reputation as a murderer
continued to follow her for the rest of
our life magazines reported false rumors
that she was a shoplifter and that she
killed baby kittens and birds when she
was a child people did not want to sit
near her in church and tell her house
was pummeled with rotten eggs on a
regular basis no one wanted to be
associated with this woman who may have
murdered her parents local children they
made up a rhyme about her murder and
enjoyed singing it outside the window
and it went as such Lizzie Borden took
an axe she gave her mother 40 whacks
when she saw what she had done she gave
her father 41 now despite all of the
criticism Lizzie never moved away to
escape the ridicule and tried to make
the best of her situation she began
attending plays at the local theater and
three parties in her new home for the
cast and crew she seemed to be
particularly infatuated with an actress
named Nancy O'Neill O'Neill was known
having a deep voice in the masculine
attitude which led some people to
believe that the two might have been
having an affair it turns out that
O'Neill was truly a great actress worthy
of admiration there because she
eventually moved to Hollywood and start
in a few movies even though Lizzie
Borden was now wealthy and live
in a good part of town she continued to
be single for the rest of her life but
she may have been concealing a hidden
romance the only real evidence of the
latter though was a letter that she
wrote to a female friend saying
something rather romantic I dreamed of
you the other night but I dare not put
my dreams on paper for some unknown
reason Emmer and Lizzy got into an
argument and EMA decided it was time for
her to move out of Fall River
she moved far away to escape the bad
reputation that the Borden name had
brought them and the sisters never saw
each other again some people believe
that this is proof of Lizzie's Gilson
that she must have confessed to Emma
however Emma left shortly after one of
Lizzie's big parties in which the
actress Nancy O'Neill was in attendance
some people believe that it may be more
likely that she was caught in a lesbian
affair or Emma simply disapproved of her
new lifestyle Lizzie Borden continued to
live alone in her Maplecroft mansion for
the rest of her life she died at the age
of 66
she left a significant portion of her
estate to the full River Animal Rescue
League in her will she also left
thousands of dollars to each of her
close friends and cousins today both her
childhood home by the reverenced maple
croft mansion were purchased by an
investor and turned into museums to this
day people still speculate whether
Lizzie Borden truly killed her parents
but will probably never know so I really
hope you found their video interesting
as always at that like button if you did
why not also subscribe to this channel
for brand new videos twice a week
Mondays and Thursdays and let us know
how we're doing in the comments below
we'd love to hear from you suggestions
what you thought of this one what you
thought of other ones just let us know
we'd love to hear from you and as always
thank you for watching
[Music]